under the basket kicks it out quickly
short on the three got his own Miss puts
it back up and in great hustle and
contact under the basket temper's Flair
which we expected at some point in this
series security gets on the floor
exposed her out there as well peeling
his player Cody Martin away from
hartenstein now Tom Thibodeau is walked
down Court
see also that Zeller was in that in that
group of people here so there were three
guys there's a lot of contact there
[Applause]
tempers starting to flare here Jimmy
Butler uh having a little fun with it
and we'll see what they call here with
14.7 seconds remaining
in the third quarter
now you gotta see underneath while
Randall pushed Zeller in the back seller
first and then all of a sudden
then you see Martin and Martin's side
okay Martin pushes
remember that the initial is just keep
an eye so you can see Zeller pushing
there and then Martin's side pushes so
Zeller was the initial
and the defensive player meaning
Granville goes down and then the push
continues you're going to see it right
there
right on top of it but then Martin comes
in to see and then puts puts pressure
I would be upset also because you get
pushed from the rear you're not seeing
anything the other thing they have to
look at here is did anybody leave the
bench for either team here yeah that
would be horrible
so I'll continue to look here at this
weather to call technical fouls and this
goes back to Randall getting tangled up
after that screen with Zeller and then
there was a foul a possession or two
later where when Randall got off who
made a little contact to the chest of
Zeller
and there you see the end result now